à 69 ans Matsumoto les J est un des
auteurs de manga les plus réputés au
Japon
vous n'allez pas le croire mais la
galaxie se trouve au fond de la rue à
droite
excité comme des puces nous avons
débusqué dans cette tanière le père du
corsaire de l'espace
l'homme sort peu c'est dans le secret de
ce pavillon de banlieue qu'il élabore
ces odyssée futuristes
exceptionnellement le maître nous a
accordé aux dents
à 69 ans Matsumoto lei est un des
auteurs de manga les plus réputés au
Japon
dans sa mensualité extrême il nous a
livré quelques-uns de ses secrets
stellaires
pour dessiner les étoiles je me sers
d'un collier de plomberie
je trempe un pinceau dans cette peinture
blanche et le fraude contre le fermoir
pour projeter de fines bulles sur la
page
[Musique]
a priori les êtres vivants c'est moi qui
m'en charge
il n'y a que les motifs de kimono que je
délègue à mes assistants
[Musique]
les Japonais ont associé textes et
images dans son footoir merveilleux le
maître possède une pièce de musée
à dessiner des images sous le titre
officiel de manga
a été publié en 15 volumes et date de
regardez le mouvement de l'homme ça
ressemble à de l'animation
[Musique]